[Music]
all right
looks like i did everything right
the ship is afloat
welcome
to a whole new world
see some people already in the chat
praising jeff bezos
as we all should should we should we all
raise jeff bezos
all right
so
if you didn't know
based off the title based off my
beautiful song in the beginning
this is
new world
it is an open beta right now open beta
from the 9th yesterday until the 12th
which is sunday i think i see somebody
in the chat i mentioned that as well
and um so i've gone ahead and created a
character
uh i named him
damien
but the way i wanted to spell it was
already taken
on this server so i had to get really
weird with it so it looks like they mean
we're
you know kind of looks like he's a red
dead character right now so
a wow and final fantasy 14 killer well
it might
it might put a dent in wow
there's a possibility considering
everything that's going on with
activision blizzard so it might put a
dent in wow it is like a little
different from from wild gameplay so i
can see that final fantasy 14 killer i
haven't played that myself so i'm not
sure
but
i don't think it's gonna kill that one
all right so let me just remind yourself
what i'm up to oh yeah so
like i was saying previously made a
character went through most of the
tutorial stuff we are ever fall right
now
and
basically
i'm at the stage where you get to pick
one of the three factions
um so i need to go speak
to all three of them
who i am going to uh to side with what
gang am i gonna join
which volume are you talking about me
the uh
or the game volume
david this is new world
new mmo
rpg from amazon game studios
technically it should have been out out
by now
but it got delayed from august to the
end of september
one thing i wish right off the bat
um yesterday
is i wish there was a mini map
am i am i crazy for for wanting that i
just want something down in the corner
so
i can
do more than just follow the compass at
the top because i feel like i get a
little turned around
more than i should
even right now okay here we go
because you know like for example
so i come around here and look at all of
these these people and all of these
things to interact with
and it's just like all right well who
who am i talking to
looking for a yellow one oh that person
has a yellow over their head is that who
i'm supposed to talk to no this person
with nothing over their head but they're
in front of the
faction thing so this is what i'm
supposed to do who's brave enough to
approach the marauder commander
richie what up
welcome this i know routine i know this
isn't call of duty you know there are
guns in this game though
um so but it's not like vanguard like
you were playing earlier but that you
know you can't shoot people
braver tell me about the marauders the
marauders are a community of warriors
who believe in self-improvement
if we are blessed with eternal life we
should use it to sharpen our combat
skills to perfection okay cool
well that's it
oh
give me something to do or give me a
little more of a taste of
what that faction would be like
now that i know it's just talking it
feels like
like even though i i wasn't i wasn't a
part of any uh fraternities or anything
but
back when i was in college and just had
the fraternities
action
to figure out
[Music]
in this world there are those who think
and those who do not
we
are the former and we look down
we believe in facts and
science i don't know man i kind of
i kind of like
them i like their logo i like the color
purple
like
i don't know they're winning me over
just because of that and they made
themselves seem really smart they were
just kind of like hey would you seek
knowledge
it reminds me of that that dude i'm
blanking on his name with
the meme of that guy
these are all my cars that i fall with
knowledge
welcome to my library of knowledge
all right last one
they gotta do something real crazy to
sell me i am here on behalf of the
covenant seeking those who are similarly
inspired i see let me see tell me about
the covenant do i see the spark of
righteousness in this one
in a world beset by darkness
we are the lion you are the light i see
let's see
oh and now that i've spoken to all of
them i just i get that decision right
there instead of just leaving uh
all right now i have to choose
real talk it doesn't i don't think it
really matters
like based off of what i saw of the game
before
uh this open beta when it was closed
betas which i weren't a part of um
the factions don't really matter
cosmetically their armor looks a little
bit different but like
i don't think it really matters all that
much
so i think we're gonna go with purple
gang
there's also a lot of purple gang out
here so uh
we might be wrapping the right side by
going with purple they have knowledge
hey evan
welcome to the stream
hey hey onyx
wake up all right we're we're joining
i don't remember the name of them i
think they're syndicated we're joining
syndicate onyx all right i think it's
going down all right here we go
if you keep sleeping you're going to
miss out you're going to miss out on
everything we're doing with what's in it
i see that inquisitive sparkle in your
eye here we go imagine our lives
technically not because we can we can
leave that a faction we can switch
and then there's like a 120-day cooldown
if you switch factions
this beta isn't long enough for me to
like
care about that right now but um just
throwing that info out there
and look at that why join a faction
all right so you get you complete
missions you get extra stuff you can
control
there's
territory
pvp stuff that goes on with it you get
access to extra gear and like i said
that gear looks different
depending on
which faction you're a part of which is
kind of cool
and then the pvp and faction war so like
something to know about me when it comes
to like these
mmorpgs and stuff
um i usually don't like to play like pvp
stuff but we're gonna we're gonna check
it out
free copies of syndicate if you join
hey listen that's one of the ones the
one of the assassin's creeds i haven't
played is syndicate uh like sin i bought
unity and it just sat on my playstation
4 and never played it and syndicate i
never even gave a chance so if the free
copy comes with joining this faction
that's cool with me
territory control territory influence
um
this is
why i think i will like
pvp in new world more
than i have in previous games
flat for pvp from any settlement by
pressing you
okay so what we'll come back
i thought i just signed my life away
before
now now you're giving me like a second
chance to think about it all right cool
we have proud warriors
divine
we're still going with this we're still
going with them
even though now that they're giving me a
second chance i have a moment to like
think about it and i kind of want to
just go with the green gang
purple gang purple gang all the way we
said we would there we go there's that
120-day cooldown that i was talking
about now that you are wonderful we're
not going back on it you will have
access to vast knowledge
in time
but first
i have a challenge for you
you're sure to have seen the crimson
corrupted forces that terrorize this
island of arcane mysteries
the war between the corrupted and the
living is more important than any petty
the corrupted have overtaken a farm
called bradberry fields
for the syndicate's research
i get to get the red purple
clothing and die what
that's good wasn't it wasn't the gang in
uh san andreas
wasn't gross street purple
or am i mixing it up
it's horrible if i'm mixing it
um
uh
is this also on ps5
no sorry
this is not also on ps5 and only
for
pcr
unfortunately
that's that's the other reason i feel
like it won't be a final fantasy 14
killer because that that is uncommon
right
so there's still going to be people that
you know maybe don't have a pc but want
to
get into an mmo
so they're going to go to something
oh the ballers were purple no
we should have been green
i mean we can switch we can switch all
right
nobody nobody tell cj
grove street we're green oh man no
nobody tell cj all right
yeah no problem
and i love that they're paying me no
attention all right let's run right now
unless unless
[Music]
wow
a little more active a little more
involved just
clicking clicking click and clicking and
having them
do all the random swipes and dodges for
you
all right all right all right relax
[Music]
now that i know
now that i know of my mistake
can't hear me oh okay
gotcha gotcha that's what i was asking
someone earlier
i was asking what uh
if my audio was too low earlier because
someone had mentioned
sound but there we go
thank you
for letting me know
bring the game volume down a little more
there we go
cool so what about now
even though there's
not a lot of like fighting noise
cool cool
thank you legend thank you
my mic was too low all that time you
guys missed out on so much my rambling
i'm not a shame
i said some crazy secrets i gave away
codes to this game
wow should have said something earlier
corrupted farm hand all right bro
and uh there's also no regenerating
like health
so it's good in this game to always kind
of have food on hand
so i'm gonna eat some of that right
there
and we're going to continue on our way
make sure i'm going the right way yup
exactly
we also have hella points that after i
do this i'm going to have to go through
mess around with uh
some of my points
you got some reasons
would have been lovely is like a parry
technique
if it's in here and i don't know about
it someone let me know
i'm bleeding
okay so we need to search crates for
corrupted seeds
and destroy
corrupted
destroy corrupted that's right
okay so we've kind of already been doing
that one thing i unlocked late yesterday
and haven't really messed with much is
this bow
which
i'm not
great at using oh
rolling into a post
all right we're going back to
the way we were playing before
screw it it also seems like
some of the sounds went out
that's not just
it's not just me right
i gotta i turned myself up
and then we get into this village and
some of these grunts
of killing corrupted has gone away
weird
one piece is new world
i read like
because a friend begged me to i've read
like maybe 20 pages of a one-piece manga
and i haven't went back so
i don't know what that's in reference to
oh it looks fun but unfortunately i'm
not a pc player why not frank
frank tell me tell me why you're not a
pc player because
i had my reasons last year
and then i finally bought one like i had
my reasons like years ago and then last
year i finally bought one
and
i do still have like consoles i have a
playstation 5 xbox one switch
but man having a pc
kind of changed my life i'm gonna be
real with you
the amount of sales the amount of free
games through just like epic game store
alone the amount of
different types of games you can like
mess around with and play
it's been a real game changer for me in
the last year how many do we need we
need two more corrupted we gotta kill
two more it seems like our
grunts are back
so whatever was happening
what is this streaming lady
renat what do what do you mean
we're streaming
streaming new world what are you what
are you trying to say
another thing
we're gonna we're gonna talk about some
things i don't like here
another thing
is this little jump this tiny tiny jump
like you can vault over stuff
but like
this this little this little baby jump
right here
maybe i have to upgrade some stuff let's
uh
let's go in here okay that's what it is
maybe
if i upgrade like dexterity maybe my
jump will
go up as well i know this you know it
helps with a lot of these weapons but
all right we got eight of those well i
guess i will come back to that
rest in peace gentian impact no
definitely not
definitely wouldn't call this the
gentian impact killer either
why because gentian impact is free
boom
jensen empire is impact said that weird
it's free
so i really do not see this
during that either
um
this is going to be 40 bucks
but unlike something like wow there will
be no subscription
which
is a big selling point for me
oh and over on the twitch chat sorry i
was just looking at youtube chat for a
little bit over on the twitch chat
uh mr yellow asked if you have to
pre-order to play in this beta and if
you're still around mr yellow no you do
not this is the open beta um and it will
be open until the 12th so you do not
have to pre-order this
to play in it i believe you just have to
go to the steam page and
request it i don't know what the
what it is now because i i've requested
it before the game
uh before the open beta was released
then you had to like request it and then
it will like show up in your library
you might have to do that same thing
will this ever go to console uh i doubt
it
with the way things are going from like
pc to console and console to pc
sorta a chance
but like
it it's like probably way out there in
the future they haven't announced
anything about it coming to
um
consoles in the future so
if you're really hyped for it i wouldn't
say just wait around to see if it's
coming off the console
maybe your budget doesn't allow for it
right now and things like that
but if you can
get a pc man jump in
jump in the new world john purple gang
mind that ore
chop that wood
we will we probably will be dropping
some
right now we're just kind of killing
people and destroying things
but there are skills that i haven't
really
gotten up there yet like
you know smelting woodworking stone
cutting all of this stuff
still way down there logging is zero so
we
really gotta start cutting some trees
our resume for wood cutting
not getting a job out here
all right we need
one more
of those corrupted chests
i
don't see one all right you take care of
him
because i gotta go find something
gonna ignore him oh here we go
found you
stop you violated the law hand over all
the cabbages
listen
i'm down with purple gang and with
purple gang we don't we don't pay
attention to the laws all right we also
really like cabbage so we're going to
take what we need
we're ridding
this area this whole area
with the cabbages we're ridding it of
the corrupted okay all right just don't
don't attack me that's cool too
okay now we need to kill carl
carl
where are you
are you him oh you're him
you're him alright
here we go
[Music]
take that call
listen all right carl's dead you don't
have a leader anymore you don't have to
do this
well i guess they have to do it
there we go let's see
good gear no whammies good gear no
whammies
okay all right we got a leather coat
we got a leather coat all right
um actually i was about to go into my
menus right here let's not do that
because carl is going to respawn right
there
and probably kick our ass so let's move
away from here
and then find a spot to uh
grub out on some food can i eat the
cabbage i know i know in the chat you
know i just got yelled after chilling
cabbage but i'm wondering
if i can eat the cabbage oh
chill bro chill hey hey hey i won't take
anymore i won't i won't do it i'm sorry
okay i'm sorry
do have a campfire available
let's just get all the way back to uh
to our little hub world
look at the chat while we run and mmo
souls like i mean i never played the
souls games but based off of what i've
seen
um all the gameplay of those
types of games
i can see why you say that
but i don't think at least the level
that i'm at right now that the combat
uh
or the encounters are as
difficult
as
a souls game
whoa
yo whoa
go back in the woods what are you doing
out here
this isn't your territory get out of
here
oh my gosh
what else are we talking about in the
chat another comments about souls likes
this is a mmorpg right yes it is
is this an uh in this mmo
you're white but at the end you become
asian don't know what that's a reference
to either sorry
but if you couldn't tell
i i'm a black
man in real life and in this game
this lady why do you think i'm a lady
i mean you know
am i
am i a pretty lady
and no i have not played a souls game i
turned on
what's it called bloodborne
uh maybe
15 minutes i've turned on bloodborne and
realized it just really wasn't for me it
wasn't my type of game and i think
that's totally fine i think some games
aren't for everyone
this game definitely probably isn't
going to be for everyone i don't even
know if it's
for for you uh renat but you know if it
is it is if it isn't that's fine
um new world nah why didn't they make
middle earth because there's already an
mmo
in middle earth
people like to say stupid things often
i'm one of them i'm guilty of it i'm
guilty of it don't worry no one's
perfect
i'm more of a story and well so i'll
skip this one
i mean this
does have a story um i don't know if
you're implying that it doesn't this
this does have a story you know the
world has been taken over by what
they're calling the corrupted um
the ship you were on in the beginning of
the game just kind of crashes into shore
because of the corrupted uh taking over
and you're just kind of here
in everfall
talking to people in in the beginning to
try to set up how you're going to deal
with all of this
um you are a beautiful souls-like lady
thank you
that means a lot it means a lot to me
ideally i recommend demon souls okay
demon souls
now i i've thought about demon souls as
well um i thought about grabbing that on
playstation and seeing what's up but
corrupted are a malignant i'll get there
i just you know my patience levels
sometimes
with these seeds we shall research ways
to use azoth and farming
similar to how the corrupted used their
red miasma okay okay
so you have aided our research by
bringing these seeds
uncovering more about our internet all
right i mean that's why i died
i greet you in reverence fellow pursuer
of knowledge all right cool we'll come
back to you in a second
we're about to dive into these menus
that's what you've been waiting for here
oh here it comes
here comes those menus
all right
take a look at the chat really quick um
are you playing solo do you like it i am
playing solo
um
do i like it
i don't hate it
i don't know if that helps i don't hate
it um i think i am
super early
in the game so
there's still so much that um
the game probably has to offer and i've
just scratched the surface i'm sure
so
i don't hate it
um
what else weak story i feel like
fetch and kill is not my cup of tea
yeah it does seem like um
those type of missions though so okay i
get what you're saying now
do you need a party to play this game or
can you play solo all right well just
like i was saying before boom
i'm playing solo i am by myself i'm not
in a party um i believe you can play a
lot of it solo but i do think there are
instances where it would be good to have
people to play with
um
and it seems like when you're taking
zones like when you're when your faction
is taking new territory that's not
something you can do by yourself
so right now i am in a zone for
syndicate my faction but oh actually no
i'm up here this is a spot they've
already taken but if we wanted to take
one of these zones
then i can't do that by myself i can
like i can't flip on uh pvp and then go
in there all leroy jenkins
and it just wouldn't work out well for
me so there are plans there are parts of
the game where you're definitely going
to need to play with other people but
for right now where i am like about to
hit level 10 still doing kind of
tutorial-ish stuff and getting to know
the game
solo's fine
reminds me of greed fall i've had greed
fall on my
playstation for a while
because i think it was a playstation
plus at one point and
i still haven't touched it but if this
is like greenfall then that's kind of
cool
um
i'm definitely gonna have to do that uh
and check that out
you're like everyone's good dad here
thank you for being a good dad benjamin
i've been so proud of you son you're
welcome you're what
keep doing what you're doing benjamin
keep doing it
the progress from this beta will be
erased question mark don't know that i
forgot to look up i might be
uh i didn't i kind of planned on
depending on how far i get in the course
of this weekend i did plan on just
completely restarting
uh
but
that's a good question i wish i had the
answer for you
um what are you guys playing right now
for me it's doom two
are you asking the chat because you know
what i'm playing renat you know what i'm
playing probably butchering your name
i'm sorry you did call me a beautiful
lady i didn't i don't mean to put your
name in the chat
okay so
um
being the good dad
that benjamin said i was
let me explain something to you guys if
you don't know
this game doesn't have classes there is
no picking of a certain class and then
leveling up and going that way
you're kind of open-ended you're an open
book
what you want to do is unwritten you
write the story yourself with
pretty much this page and with the gear
that you're using
like your your weapons and whatnot
so for me
i don't really plan on doing a lot of
like magic and stuff which is kind of
where this
lives with the staffs so i'm probably
gonna ignore some of these stats right
here and i kind of wish i knew this to
begin with honestly let's hit that
respect because it's free up until level
20. so let's start over
boom now we have 16 points
i want to jump this all the way up to 10
right now because i i feel like i'm
going to be a sword and shield guy
um and i have been messing around with
axes and hammers so i do think i want to
kind of live here this is for health
so i'm gonna bump this up because
you know let's be real i'm not great
i could use all the extra help they want
to give me all right let's be real
um
oh here we go twitch chat
came through for me aaron fx
in the toys chat we have um kobe saying
open beta will be reset it wipes before
the actual release so
everything that i'm doing here
doesn't even matter
which means
i can join the green gang later on all
right if you missed it
um
i i went and i kind of chose the wrong
uh
faction because if i was thinking about
it in san andreas granted grand theft
auto san andreas terms i should have
chosen the green one but i didn't so
what the ball is
all right so back to this
we have that where that is um dexterity
i feel like can bump up to a 10
and then
let's do strength at 11.
16 points
bam
and then over here
you get
different points in the in the weapon
mastery depending on what you're viewing
using so
as you can see i've never used the spear
i've never used like a hatchet but i
have used the great axe a little bit i
have used the warhammer a little bit and
then the bow a little more than those so
you get
points and
that
weapon set kind of levels up as you're
going so
that's why
over for attributes i'm just kind of
sticking to strength because i feel like
i'm gonna lean into these like
one-handed
uh two-handed weapons type things and
like rarely go towards magic
because i've just never i've never been
a healer type of
uh player
i don't know what that says about me
no class restriction is nice kenneth yes
yes it is i actually really like that
about it
um
because that means
you're not locked in like you can kind
of switch what you want to do at any
time like as you can see you can even
respec
these points here it's just all a matter
of getting the weapon you want if i want
to switch to magic i just
oh i have i i lied a little bit i did
use a fire staff i have that in
my inventory somewhere and i did use it
for a little bit but like i said it just
never sticks with me but if i did want
to go the magic route
boom it's right there for me
i can just start using that leveling
that up ignoring all of this stuff over
here and there you go but enough talking
for me for a second let me uh let me
figure out what i want to do so sturdy
grip
stamina damage is reduced
okay
i think i don't even
need to look at the rest of this grant's
15 physical armor i like this
i wish there was one for
evade
because when you dodge
that takes like a significant chunk of
your uh
stamina
we're gonna go with this
okay
so we did all of that
now what do we want to do oh hang on
we also have these territory standings
so
these basically give you
a
it's like there's certain things in here
that like me being new to this still
it's kind of
confusing to explain but
these points basically give you buffs
depending on which territory you're in
so
uh
i forget which ones i already have on
but as you can see
when i'm in everfall
if i choose this one my storage will be
increased by 25.
he's pretty cool
and then there's other stuff like the
trading tax um and then decreased uh
crafting fee
i haven't gotten into any of this like
tax rate stuff and all of all of that
that does seem a little more complicated
than what i'm ready to dive into maybe
this weekend though um i don't think i
need the storage right now but crafting
fees would be cool so let's do that
so now we have two and ever fall
but we have two more that i can get so
gathering speed is increased that might
come in handy we got another decrease
for crafting fee and then earn five
percent more territory standing while in
ever fall
i want gathering
so let's do that
we got storage again i think i'm gonna
go with xp that's what i did the first
time the first time i got a um territory
standing point
i use it on xp gain
so yeah so trading facts nah storage we
already said no to before so let's go
with xp game
cool
let me see
what we already have
so here we go here's the ones i already
have so like i said i already did an xp
one so i think this is just mashing them
both together and then here's the other
one i picked and the other one after
that and i have a rank four standing a
newcomer in everfall
not bad
i can't complain
upside down duck love your name
is this an mmorpg game yes it is
but it is an mmorpg game with no
subscription fee if that helps sell you
on it a little more
i'm not here to sell you on it i'm just
if you're into these types of games and
hate like subscription fees like i do
then
despite the general mood that is
definitely i have a good feeling about
things
so let me let me show you around ever
fall just a tiny bit
this over here where all these people
are is the trading post
you can go in here and buy some stuffs
um do i need arrows i might need some
arrows i should buy them while i'm here
and then you can sell some stuffs
and i
did someone buy it i think i had a oh
yeah completed cool
awesome all right
yeah yesterday um before i like stopped
playing yesterday i put up this like
pretty ugly helmet
up for sale on the trading post so okay
it sold while i wasn't playing that's
great
just while i wasn't paying attention
and this
where murdock is standing and for some
reason it won't let me
look at it there we go is my storage
so this is why i didn't do the um extra
storage as my territory standing
uh
use it with with the point that i had
because
i barely have anything in storage right
now anyway
so
i'm like screw it but that reminds me
now that i'm looking at all this and
looking at my inventory again i did get
some new armor and stuff so let's check
that out real quick
in here why am i blanking on where
it is oh i know there we go
like i was just playing last night what
show battle gameplay um do you just mean
like fighting i'll get into some fights
in a second um let me just like
switch it let me play dress up real
quick and then we'll we'll get back into
some fighting um
or do you mean like a big battle i don't
think i can get into like some of the
big territory stuff just yet i hope this
works out quit wow classic after two
months and quit runescape after two
years
yeah i mean i hope this game um
finds an audience for it even if it's
not like a killer of the other games i
do hope it finds its audience
can you go kill something and show the
combat aspect all right um
let's actually start heading that way
now since we have two requests for that
in the chat and then
maybe i'll i'll just switch some clothes
really quick once we get out here
we're probably just gonna go and
actually hang on
let's let's try to let's see if we can
get some combat from this guy if we can
get like a request
that'll give us something to do
i greet you in the thoughts so far frank
pursue like i
don't i don't remember if i answered it
when you asked me i think someone else
asked um i don't hate it
i don't love it i do like it
um i think there's some things that
it could
use to like kind of make it a little
better but i do like it let's see so
we have some of these that we can do so
this is this is all
new to me now
um i wasn't here before
but this is this is a good screen
to
point to for some of the people who are
asking about if it's if you can play
this solo so like with this mission you
can see right there it says difficulty
solo so you don't need to play it with
um
other people for
the these specific ones but i'm sure
later on there'll be some harder ones
some bigger enemies that you do need
more people to play with you
um
let's just do this first one it says
purge in it so
that should probably give us some
people to fight
what else is going on in the chat is
this on ps5 nope pc only sorry joshua
unless you have a pc then i'm then i'm
not sorry get on pc whoa
uh
uh
i figured it would disappear but like
okay did someone do that or did that
just like fall
okay smelly heels is over here chopping
trees nice
job smelly
yesterday i recorded it um
in my first day playing but coming down
this hill it was all campfires
like there wasn't a step you could take
without it being a campfire and it was
ridiculous and my frame rate dropped
like crazy
but i'm glad to see it's not
it's not there now
frank gotcha nothing
nothing game breaking
you mean like groundbreaking
yeah nothing nothing groundbreaking in
my opinion i i do like
the whole
um
you know taking territories for your
faction and stuff like that but yeah
nothing nothing groundbreaking
all right so we need to go straight
ahead
let's see what all the fuss about this
game
so far game looks gorgeous yeah hard
mode it it actually looks pretty good
um even for
you know like me i'm i'm running it on
uh high settings right now and i i think
it looks pretty good especially for you
know mmo
rpg standards i think
it's pretty gorgeous
um
and even in the like the menu before you
like log in when you're choosing your
character
like i feel like the character model
really shines more
when you're um on that screen
but like even the character models not
that bad
there is a there are
some bad haircuts there's one in
particular
when you go to make a character that's
just like
nah
this ain't it bro
but my guy right now he uh i actually
gave him like a pretty crazy afro and
this this is i want to see something
really quick let's see
um
chain skin
so that's how you hide it all right i
did see that online yesterday because i
didn't want that
red dead redemption looking hat on me
i wanted him to be out here and his big
frizzy
haired natural look
just looking again gorgeous he woke up
like this
all right who am i who am i killing here
do we murder him
we got the gang i wanted to be a part of
out here
doing some things
hey hey hey you
are you the one i'm supposed to be i'm
defeating the lost are you the lost
i found you are you are you hey
don't run
i'm trying to talk to you
all right well he's gone let's not let's
not even bother
i'm trying to do combat luffa i'm trying
he ran away
he didn't want the smoke
what do you want me to do here we go
all right so with with my play style i
have a sword and shield
so you have your block
you have a slash
hi oh man you have a dodge and i
unlocked forgetting the name of it
but oh man
it's that move right there
a little spinny move
and then i have a shield dash
that i can use as well
oh that did count as one of the people i
was supposed to get okay
i don't think i fought one of these guys
just like throwing
all right um i did see a different sword
in here an uncommon one oh i haven't
tried a rapier yet
let's see this item can be found
too if you equip it
hmm
sure
all right so now we have a rapier
and he doesn't even block with his uh
shield anymore
i think our moves will be quicker with
this one
[Music]
i like this
makes me feel like a pirate
all right this this might be this might
be my my go-to oh oh no
[Applause]
i lost those other um
moves that i had
all right let's eat some food
all right
so let's wait for that food to work a
little bit more
and let's just
shoot you from far away a little bit
yeah you're throwing stuff i i got
projectiles too look at me ha
you're not the only one
oh headshot what
there's also um
like different enemies kind of
are more vulnerable to different types
of
weapons i don't know that yet
and i don't remember the each like the
damage the numbers that you see popping
up they're colored
depending on what type of like damage
you're doing to them
so one is like critical one is like not
that effective one is effective
i don't remember what's what
i do really like this rapier though
yeah it looks like i'm fencing
i like that too i've always i always
wanted to uh try out fencing
this is my way
whoa
there goes the grunts again grunt's
disappearing where'd they go
amazon i wanna i wanna hear
his growls
bring the grouse down there we go hey
mastery two we're on our way
with this weapon at least
hey how did you hate me
oh man i was just playing
oh oh you're going to get your boys
i was kidding guys
i was joking
all right they're they're not playing
games they don't want they want this
around
i'm god
take that
i should not be messing around i have no
food hold up
i have no food and i'm out here
messing around oh oh all right
if there's anybody in the chat that
wants to see a death we might we might
see it
and i didn't set up a campfire before
coming in here
rookie wait i do have food what am i
talking about
am i blind oh my gosh
what is happening
yeah someone did say that it looks like
greed fall
which means i gotta check out grief all
jellyfish yo
yo
oh my goodness
okay we're just uh we're gonna run let's
hit that auto run
let's uh let's uh get away from here
let's get away from here
is it out right now nope but it comes
out on september 28th it was supposed to
be out right now
um
just crashed but
it got delayed
so uh
this is the open beta
it will be out for a while it will be
out in a while a little while
hey
thanks
look at you
that's teamwork right there
i don't even think they're in my uh um
not my clan what's it called what's it
called faction
look at that that's nice
i want to be a healer just to do that
and help people out like that let's eat
some food because they didn't heal us
all the way
yup i think it is for beta yep it is the
beta that's all it is right now is the
beta
let me scroll up a little bit see what
type of things i missed
this almost looks like the witcher
jellyfish that's one thing that i like
about it
it kind of reminds me of the witcher if
you can see behind me um yeah it's
showing on stream you can see behind me
those are all witcher figures and in
front of me there's the map of uh the
northern realms from the witcher there's
the like wolf emblem up on my wall
big witcher fan right here so
there is something about this that is
giving me witcher vibes um
and that's a good thing
it's a real good thing
for me
um let me just look a little more at the
chat
cole my day
has been pretty great
it's been pretty great um
i'm glad i'm here with all of you in my
first
gamespot stream playing a pretty cool
game
um
wait so you can play it right now just
crashed yeah uh it's open beta so open
beta until the 12th so this weekend um
if you have pc yeah you can grab this
over on steam you should be able to
um
i don't know what the request process is
like now that um
the open beta is actually out because
before
it was
released
like i had to go to the steam page hit
request and then the next day it showed
up in my life so i'm not sure if you
still have to hit request so if you can
just like
hit open data i haven't
checked
um but yeah jump in
test it out for yourself go through
early question stuff like i was doing
just get a feel for it
even though i'm not like in love with it
i do feel like
this is something i can see myself
playing
um
i know eventually i would probably need
like a crew to play with me but this
does feel like something i can see
myself playing especially for 40 bucks
40 bucks no subscription no monthly
subscription
why not you know
take a couple
couple days to just
mess around do do some quests every now
and then like it seems like a pretty fun
world to like just kind of exist in
for a little bit
i never liked the witcher i'm more of a
not magic stuffing combat lover okay
i get that i get that
i'm like half and half um
whereas like like in this in the
beginning like i was saying i don't
want to play really too much with the
magic in this game
but like in the witcher having like it's
in the witcher it's not
a whole lot it's just a couple signs
here and there like
that's where i think it's like oh okay i
can deal with this i'm using my sword
and everything much more there's just
the occasion that boom i'm throwing fire
boom i'm like cloaking myself in a
little more armor um
using magic or putting a barrier on the
ground to slow my enemy
so
it
i i don't want to say it's like
kind of it's i will say it's like
bioshock in a way to me where it's like
the majority of that game i am shooting
a lot but every now and then i'm popping
out that hand to shoot bees at somebody
but it's not my main source of combat
it's like helping me out
i greet you in reverence fellow pursuer
also with the witcher you know she's
sending me down a rabbit hole here but
you also have like the um
the oils and stuff that you can put on
your blade so aside from the magic in
that game um you also are getting buffs
in combat in your sword play through
other means not just like magic and
stuff even though
can we call like potions magic
there's a lot of magic in the witcher
world but you get what i'm saying
all right
boom i am known now i'm no longer a
newcomer in ever fall i am known
they know my name
all right
so i showed off
combat a little bit
let's see what's up with these clothes
what's with these there's like binding
items like is it because they're not um
they're not common because when i
was shifting back and forth between
common items it wouldn't give me that
so i guess it's just and there it is
again i wish it was like a say yes to
all type button
yo wait ah guys i uh i forgot i had a uh
pirate captain's hat in here
with the rapier in the
the pirate hat like we could have really
been a pirate
oh man missed opportunity i'm missing
opportunities all over the stream
goodness
play all the three dlc included played
all the three dlcs included with uh the
witcher
i that's where i'm lacking
you know i've watched the show i've read
the books i played um three
like one in point 25 times
i started witcher one started witch or
two but didn't finish it but i i also
didn't finish the dlc's for witcher
what's wrong with me
let's see what do you say here he needs
a big ass assault to smash enemies in
the head like in dark souls hold up
it's not a big sword i don't have a big
sword yet but hard mode
look at this
this hammer is huge
like i don't know if weapons get bigger
than this but whoa
let me try to do like a power attack
boom
i wish like
what's the earth shook when you did that
or something like the screen shook
no i was talking about bioshock oh okay
i got you
and then the axe
is pretty big too but not as big
as that hammer that hammer is wild i
feel like the axe is
the uh
you know the handle and whatever is is
bigger than the actual
part you're hitting people with
where is where's the rapier again there
it is the green one
okay so
we have this coat let's rock the coat i
actually like his look right now all
this leather we got going on actually
let's see can we can we dye it now i
didn't have dye before
oh my god what's happening here
look at this
my hair is just kind of
okay
cool
um doesn't look like i can
dye anything that's
oh wait here we go here we go got it oh
[Music]
i don't know i like the brown but like
that's a little extra i think we're i
think we might go with it though
oh man what we can only use it once
that sucks
dang i thought we once we had dive we
can like put it on everything
wow just putting it on my gloves makes
it my hands
it doesn't even look like they're gloves
it just looks like i have purple hands
let's see what about purple pants
okay
the purple pants with the with the brown
and everything all right i like that
that's not that bad it's not that bad
hold up hold up everybody i'm sorry
we're playing uh
playing dress up right now
uh shield shield
turn
turn turn around bro turn turn turn turn
turn turn turn
there we go
ah purple shield not feeling it
what about uh my hat that's completely
messed up up there let's see purple
no
we're not keeping the hat on anyway all
right so we need uh more dyes
to
do everything
let's change skin on the hat what does
it look like if we put on the hat
you know you know i don't hate it you
know
i don't hate it it doesn't match
at all
but i don't hate it
i don't hate it
thanos's hand yo
wait
hang on so all right
see in my head i was thinking like
like some type of hulk character or like
grimace even though grimace doesn't have
fingers like mcdonald's uh germans
you're totally right
and i think we're gonna rock with that
we're gonna make him look weird
all brown
captain's hat
thanos hands
all he needs
is uh an infinity gauntlet
thank you thank you hard mode thank you
so much um
for that recommendation
give me a second here
lately my allergies have been crazy
so sometimes my eyes will just start
burning as if i didn't take allergy
medicine this morning
i know right now
all of you are probably thinking yeah
yeah right allergies devonte yeah you're
just
you're realistically you're you're
crying because of hard mode's great idea
to walk around with thanos hands
uh okay maybe because of our standing or
not maybe that helped
thanks
surely you've noticed the towers of the
ancients you know i haven't done
anything with charms yet so
this could be kind of interesting
um
what about you now here comes a proud
warrior if i've ever seen one some
skulls knocked man i want to see if i
can get artificial how long are you
doing
for
an hour
we'll stream for a little bit more and
then i'll hop off i have some other
stuff i gotta take care of you know real
important stuff
but thanks everybody who is here um
whether you're you know
youtube twitch all that
well i did some scouting and it's the
worst pirates of stonehenge menacing
let's see
um
we need to go to
where's
two two oh man you're far
all right maybe we won't do that one
that's far away
perfectly balanced
oh
who was that is that thanos in the room
right now
whoa
someone someone call uh marvel games
give me give me on some vo that was
impressive right right right everybody
right right tell me that was really
impressive
how good is the campaign
well i'm level nine
um i've done some like
little tutorial stuff here and there
it's
not amazing
uh but it's not horrible either you know
you're just right now i'm in the
beginning of
uh hey you need to get rid of help us
get rid of this corrupted you know and
this ever fall is pretty much in the
beginning stages of how they're gonna
really deal with this corrupted issue
um
so maybe it gets better maybe there's
there's some plot points in here that's
just like whoa
i can't believe that happened
whoa
can't believe she said that
that's so crazy
but for right now it's it's pretty chill
i oh i want a mini map so bad where am i
supposed to go am i going up
where is constable
macia
whoa
did a character in here just let out a
huge fart
i mean i don't mean to be a like a fifth
grader and just
laugh with everyone about
potty humor but i heard it i heard it it
was in here i heard it
xbox is dead looks crap xbox is dead
joke's on you this isn't for xbox
so regardless of how this looks
xbox is still gonna be moving baby
still gonna be moving
hey scott you like
clowns that's great
thanks for coming in chat and telling us
that scott i really appreciate that
okay
it was in that building right ahead
scott
help me out
it was in that building did you see
constable in there
help me out scott
i need you now more than ever
you're not who i'm supposed to be
talking to though
you know you're you're a player
character
oh wait
okay okay
all right
i was looking
at her first name
i wasn't paying attention
i need new glasses
it's clear it's clear to me now
does this game require a monthly
subscription martin
no
no it doesn't 40 bucks that's it
no monthly subscription 40 bucks you're
in boom enjoy it
that's it
it's the only npc there i know
that's what was confusing me i was like
there's only one in this building we
checked upstairs
like
i'm sorry i did i was looking at the
first name or for it to actually say
constable
and then her last name
sorry
my bad
also also kubloo
if you knew that was constable macia
why didn't why didn't you help me
we i thought we were in this together
let's see how it is
i only trust hard mode and scott
all right
said well we'll probably oh man okay so
maybe we'll just do one of these things
and then
we'll peace out
is there any way to make
all other players invisible i don't
think so
i don't think so
i know for one
i hid the chat
because there was a like a bunch of chat
over here on the side
like this
and i hid all of that
um from the feed
because it was showing up like during
game play and i didn't just didn't want
that
so
i don't know if you can make everyone
invisible
i think that
just kind of i might almost defeat the
purpose of it being an mmorpg but if
other mmos do that and i just never
noticed
let me know
but um being in the heart of town like
this that's probably why it's so packed
and i'm sure on launch day it'll be even
crazier but yeah i don't think there's a
way to hide everyone because it does get
annoying when you're going to try to
talk to someone and then there's just a
huge crowd around them
and one you can barely get the interact
button to pop up because there's so much
around them but two then you you can't
even see them when they're talking
you're just looking at like another
player's uh
face or whatever
oh
cool blue i'm sorry
i'm sorry get get that get that work
done i know you're a hard worker you
know i was just playing i know we're in
this together
you know you i just you know maybe you
could have told me a little sooner but i
i know i know you're
you're working out there i see you i see
you i'm working too
in a different way but i'm working too
um martin thanks mate we'll keep an eye
on how it develops always hesitate to
early adopt mmos i feel that
i feel that i feel that
most old asian mmos have that feature
interesting
yeah maybe it's like hidden in the um
in the options in here somewhere and i
just don't know about it or
maybe it's something amazon will
probably do for
launch or whatever
um
i would rather them figure out a thing
for the campfires because like i said
like sometimes you'll just be walking
down a road and there'll be a crap ton
of campfires
that's just out there
and it really like gets in the way and
is annoying to see and if you set up a
campfire yourself it's like
where do i where where is mine
but it's it's manageable today all it's
it seems like there's just a little bit
of campfires here and there
all right so let's try to make it to one
of these
and then we'll stop in about
what's that word
10 minutes
what are those words
over here in the twitch twitch chat we
have someone saying that weeping and
peeing wants a perfectly normal reaction
when playing a souls-like game
yeah
yeah definitely crying for me definitely
definitely crying frustration crying you
know maybe not peeing myself but
crying when playing a souls game
definitely
100.
hopefully the sun dipping in and out
hasn't like been too crazy
on me up here i don't think it should my
camera's on auto
yeah
world bosses i did hear at least in the
previous beta the closed betas i did
hear that was an issue with this
um
that you'll have a ton of people just
waiting for an enemy or a boss to
respawn
um
and it it became problems for some
people who
couldn't complete that quest
for maybe hours
because there was just so much
going on in front of that boss
and then if you're
um
like magic and
you know maybe it's taking longer for
your hits
to reach that enemy and and i'm over
here with my rapier going faster than
you maybe that's the issue but
i can definitely see it being an issue
with with the bigger bosses and stuff
but
as far as i know
not able to hide everyone
i'll try to look that up this weekend
follow me over on twitter maybe i'll
tweet that out
like hey i found it
i can hide people now
even mobile mmos have that
oh man
all right here we go here we go
is this where we need to be is this
where we need to be no it's not why do i
always do that
i swear give me a mini map please
keep all the characters on screen keep
them all
give me a mini map
and maybe it's the witcher in me and
stuff maybe that's why i want a mini map
even though wow has a mini map right
there's a reason i want a mini map and
maybe that's in the settings too i've
looked for it but i can't find that so
don't kill the doggos listen if the dogs
come after me
i gotta do what i gotta do
gotta do what i gotta do
okay is this where i'm supposed to be
this is where i'm supposed to be
check this out
if you enjoy and have some fun okay jay
thank you
hope you really enjoy your weekend
whatever you're getting into this
weekend
even if it's like working or something i
hope you have a great time hey hey
get up all right
all right
just look at that hammer it's so big
all right how much time we got left
almost six minutes
maybe we can make it to one of these
other ones let's see let's see if i get
lost there's a guarantee i'm probably
gonna get lost
let's see
try using map pins to keep direction it
is it is pinned up there i just for some
reason
without
seeing it like on the mini-map or
something
it's it's weird to me
why i keep getting lost
it happens to me a little bit in um
ghost of tsushima as well because
there's no mini map in that you're just
kind of you know following the ways of
the wind
which is awesome
great gameplay mechanic
um
really creative i think but
especially with something like this
i just really would prefer a mini map
so
it's either they add that in or i just
you know stop being that guy and pay
attention
ac valhalla vibe does anyone feel the
same hmm
whoa whoa whoa
hey you're like a zombie why you got a
gun
i mean i guess because it was a human
that turned and they already had a gun
beforehand
but still come on
um
not necessarily i don't really get
valhalla vibes
um and i love doll hollow
as for as long as that game is i think
it's a little just a little too long
but at least the main story oh it's
turkey
all right so we can't kill you said
don't kill the wolves or the dogs but
can i kill this turkey
all right i can't even ask permission
because i think we're completely out of
food
so we we really need it
i can't believe it was one stab well i
guess it's smaller than uh
some of the other things that i've i've
killed like fours fours are bigger
so i get it but yeah i don't see
valhalla
love the wind and ghost of sushi
but i hate that bird ah well
the bird is all right the bird gets a
little annoying sometimes because like i
have that itch to follow it
even like i'm i'm on a path i'm and i
know that's kind of probably what they
wanted
where it's just like
you don't have these dry moments of just
like walking
um and nothing happening
um
but like sometimes that bird comes out
and i'm just like come on man but i'm
busy
let's get this other corruption
we didn't get lost that time i'm proud
of us
not me i'm proud of us like i said we're
in this together
for three more minutes
yeah killed the turkey they're vegan
the turkeys are vegan
i guess yeah that makes sense
all the turkeys i know eat cows they
beef
okay
let's get this last one
before our time is up
and then we're gonna bounce
and
i will turn in
the quest probably later on today
actually i know what i'll do i know what
i'll do
to make it go faster
all right
the third one and we didn't even get
lost but i'm sinking into the
environment
you good at game thank you
i wouldn't say that but i'm glad you did
i'm glad you did somebody had to i'm
glad you did
okay so here's here's what we're gonna
do
um instead of walking all the way back
since we're low on time we're gonna
recall to the end
now this is something that i was just
like nice
fast travel awesome and then i used it
the other day
or yesterday
and there's like a cool down on it you
can't use it for like another like
something hours i forget how many hours
we're about to see though so let's
recall 10. you can also fast travel this
way but it takes resources and
wait do i
i have that much i have enough
ah let's do this let's go to the end
turkeys are vegan question mark yes
emerson
i was i was questioning two in my head
but yes it makes sense
it makes sense
see the issue with vegans is they
i'm not i'm not gonna bash vegans you
can you can do you over there i'll leave
them alone
i've had a lot of vegan friends
vegan x's in the past
so i'll leave them alone
because predators keep the balance in
nature they they go with your uh
your thanos vibes again hard mode
alright so here we are
fast traveled
to the in recall to the inn and
was stuck in these people's bodies
because they probably did the same and
now let me check this really quick
yeah a whole hour so we can't recall
back to the end for a whole hour so this
game has a lot of walking if you're not
into a lot of walking
might not be the game for you
because also what this game needs and i
heard it doesn't have it or it won't
have it it's mounts
isn't that like a standard for mmorpgs
shouldn't you have a mount
at some point shouldn't you be able to
get one
i digress
let's go turn this in
and then
we'll peace out
and now that we know where she is
and that her name isn't what it said
over and look at this look at this bs
over there in the corner you see it do
you see it because i see it
it doesn't say
constable
mercia or macia
it says her full name this time see they
just wanted to confuse me they wanted to
confuse me
she's highlighted in everything see man
i destroyed them what up
come through this again a real champion
forever fall it seems like we have we
look it feels like we have with you
i've read that totally wrong
whatever
complete christ quest let's get that
weapons chest that rhymed
all right
i'm gonna leave her let's crack this
open
and then we're done
what do we have
a flat bow of the fighter
cool all right
so now we can get rid of that other bow
now we have an uncommon bow
that does way more damage went from 120
to 196.
beautiful
okay
that's it for me
that was fantastic
i had a lot of fun with
that play session like i said i'm not
super super in love with this game but i
do like it and like i said for 40 bucks
and no monthly subscription fee
i think it's a game i can see myself
jumping into every now and then so
i hope you guys liked it i appreciate
everybody that stopped by and helped me
through that
um
it's been fun
and
let us know if you want to see any more
new world content over here on the
channel
uh
whether it's tips and things like that
as we get closer to the actual release
of the game in
on september 28th
so
thanks again for watching
i'm out
follow me on twitter at devante chisholm